good morning Hank it's Monday I'm a man
I'm a zebra I'm a man bra oh wait that's
something else so Hank I'm here in the
great city of Chicago at a very crowded
English teachers conference which is a
lot of fun because hey I get to talk
with English teachers about books one of
my favorite endeavors and B I was
starting to miss signing my name but
before that and before the man-bra and
before a bath so luxurious and wasteful
that it made me wonder whether luxurious
and wasteful or synonyms and before we
were coming up the elevator with Henry
battling the oppression of strollers and
before I found myself at the bean and
before I ate a breakfast at a restaurant
where the hostess was a nerdfighter and
before I was reminded of the many and
varied miseries of Chicago traffic
before all that I was at brilliant audio
my audio book publisher narrating The
Fault in Our Stars so there will be two
audiobook versions one real audiobook
narrated by Kate Rudd pictured here
greeting her adoring public in a Panera
and one narrated by me
Kate sounds exactly like hazel and her
recording is brilliant I sound like a 34
year old man making for some awkward
moments here's the sample chapter six
actually no we must avoid all spoilers
my recording will be available only in a
physical limited edition boxset
available at dftba.com case recording
will be the real audiobook and available
everywhere the reason it's possible to
have two audiobooks one released by
dftba records and one released by
brilliance is that they worked with me
to share the audio publishing rights in
a really cool and innovative way and hey
Gwen copyright law works that's how it
works nice people sometimes with lawyers
get together and figure out what's fair
so I can your last video you talked
about copyright intellectual property
and correctly pointed out that the
measures currently before Congress on
this topic are a steaming hot slice of
crazy which is now apparently a
vegetable but that's it copyright is
really complex like obviously you're not
violating my copyright if you post a
quote from my book on your tumblr and
obviously you are violating my copyright
if you post my book on your tumblr but
the question of where you draw that line
is really complicated and ill-defined so
I don't a lot of people will say that
creative comments can bypass all of
these problems but I don't think so I'm
a big fan of Creative Commons and hate
you and I have both released a lot of
stuff from songs to zombie apocalypse
novellas via Creative Commons licenses
but I just don't think it's practical
for everything okay so let me give you
an example of a complexity of fair use
and the kind of chilling effect it can
have on discourse in 2004 I was
finishing a novel called Looking for
Alaska and the nice lawyers that penguin
decided that the character Alaska
well it's too much of an Edna st.
Vincent Millay poem the poem begins
night falls fast today is in the past
blown from the dark hill hitter to my
door
three flakes then four arrive then many
more they decided that under fair use I
could only quote two lines of the poem
and that if I wanted to quote more I
would have to pay Edna st. Vincent
Millay estate which I would have done
except I didn't have any money so I get
the same situation today I would just
pay and use the quote and it would be
fine because now thanks to copyright
I've sold some books and I have enough
money to pay for that kind of thing so
one of my big issues with copyright law
is that currently it privileges people
like 2011 me who have 500 bucks or
whatever to pay Edna st. Vincent Millay
estate and it punishes people like 2004
me who don't have that money and the
really terrifying thing to me about the
legislation currently before Congress is
that it would increase that inequality
YouTube and Google and tumblr can afford
lawyers to fight lawsuits from Viacom
but I can't meanwhile this legislation
will do nothing to stop wholesale piracy
because it is already illegal peg in the
end it only made my book a little bit
worse to lose those lines and I'm gonna
disagree with the alarmists I suspect
that if SOPA were to pass it would only
make the internet a little bit worse but
the internet doesn't need to be worse it
needs to be better and I don't think
SOPA is pushing us in the right
direction at all so Hank that's my take
and you can trust me I'm a man bro
nerdfighters let's continue the
conversation in comments Hank I will see
you on Wednesday